yutz exclusion aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur le code simulator ya un
nouveau dlc qu'est sortie qui s'appelle
gauche veut comme d'eyes et en face à
leurs dettes une parodie des survival
horror qu'on connaît comme days h1n1 et
toutes ses bêtises c'est parti pour plus
tard c'est génial une toute nouvelle map
on est maintenant dans la dent avant
l'infection et du compte c'est nous apte
à une vieille chef qui lance infections
en fait où une petite statuette
oui affection la secte autres haleine
tous les autres faits quoi c'est génial
c'est l hébreu à funchal
elle va affecter les gens à faire ce
qu'ils disent au lac et al comment sonne
l'heure sa vitesse
l'infection a commencé de wever blues ou
quoi obligé avant une affection sa
convenance
hop hop hop etes-vous prêts les jurys
hop là [ __ ] ça en slow motion et où al
alam et qu'elle figure alors dit sur
tout ça pour vous récompenser les
enfants je vais tous les insectes est
allé cordialement leur génération de
zombies à la joie qu'on va passer dans
le à la phase infection du coup c'est le
chaos c'est la guerre aux mondiaux il
agresse les gens les gens quittent dos à
dos comme snoop dogg un bel effort
[ __ ] des vaisseaux aliens attaquent la
ville à joliette il ya des avants postes
de garde et où gates survival life allez
c'est parti à temps pour doucher enfermé
quoi a vaincu la petite cage
moi je vais dire et kraft est une arme
j'ai pas le temps je crois que j'ai pas
encore ce qu'il faut pour kraft est un
truc un béton [ __ ] ou de la bouffe est
si mince et que les zombies sur le très
intelligent quoi au delà je devais ziba
tu me tapes à travers aller à dieu je me
tire mais je vais crever de faim mais ça
pue ça commence à des 108 la barre de
fin on va tester la force d'une chèvre
boss les autres jours de l'invasion mais
c'est quoi ça me paraît tout à fait time
bomb dessus h est décédé ok c'est
reparti jour 1a les bars et vous bordel
on va faire tout les trucs fait rentrer
dans cette maison où tout de suite vous
inspire
allez allez peut-être fait une barricade
vous infecterait bande de bâtards je
vais les trouver j'ai je sens qu'ils
sont cachés quelque part mais arrêtez
tout barricadé [ __ ] vous est
insupportable à fin mai le bordel mon
gars au regard des amis qu est ce qu il
faut la fin de l'an nous arrêtent et le
passé ou là elle est passée où ta copine
elle est là à temps elle a traversé le
mur quoi le boeuf à lecci t elle fait
partie des x men c'est sûr ici c'est
l'institut xavier vraiment regardé
xavier juste de la danse on lit des cdo
ryan cazilhac est sûre gbagbo lé nom
c'est quoi ça anichebe à ok c'est ça qui
explose marine
allez c'est quelqu'un qui comprend ce
qui se passe actuellement
s'il vous plaît coli stratégique [ __ ]
oui c'est bon ça oh oui c'est bon ça
fait quoi annick et à regarder ça c'est
un truc secret ça regardez hop hop hop
j'ai raté bonjour monsieur
oh la la c'est génial c'est tard c'est
un bon mec sans quoi il ya des gens qui
sont pas affectés en fait regarder ils
sont posés soit un barbecue à non non ah
oui dans quelles raisons qui seraient
passés par là watt et ya que moi qui
suis une fièvre ici lé battle de chèvre
engager mon gars tiens ma couille omex
et wipeout et allez c'est parti gauche
wipeout ces partis ni quel boss
non ça va continuer à jouer en sommes
voilà c'est un essai mais c'est déjà
fini j'en ai pas c'est tiers commence
vraiment à m'énerver elle me suit et
[ __ ] de honte on rattrapera jamais
bordel en place christian adam ça sent
le la joie pas du tout à ça que sert
guitare elle fut atteint carrément
l'opposé de la joie va t'en à tence et
intuitive en dessert quand il ya un mort
donnant déjà ça suffit quoi cercueil
d'occasions c'est un peu glauque m
alors ici il ya aucune infection quoi ça
s'éclate depuis des mois ah non non non
mais non je suis désolé
ayew mais toi je vais défoncer je prends
le ballon je te le met dans la tête
voilà allons nous en sommes [ __ ] je
vais tomber c'est sûr c'est sûr non non
non non non non je vous aurais bordel
non non oui on a vu une tombe sans
déconner ça je suis sûr c'est un truc
secret attention vous allez voir on va
rentrer dedans et ça va décoller non
alors voilà peta qui si je tâcherai dit
non mais un peu loin quand même le
retour au point de départ
moi je vais faire du toboggan qu'elle a
ou pas papa mais ya que des gens
bizarres dont je perçois d'encourager
ces gentils c'est gentil vraiment merci
d'encourager ses gentillette willy force
de tout en haut mais à temps et si
j'atterris ce truc là bas oh oui est ce
parce qu'injuste 2007 c'est quoi c'est
quoi ça un éléphant avec une voiture sur
le dos il faut absolument que j'aille
dans cette voiture là on revient avec
deux ans déjà attendait c'est comme ça
qu'on apprivoise un éléphant les gars
taper dans les fesses toujours les
fesses jouait dans la voiture
dieu éléphant jeter abandonne
il a du coup ça peut faire un bateau par
contre si on va dessus non c'est un jeu
c'est ça et hop voilà nickel
j'ai pas le temps aux attentions ça lui
allait toi tu le fais je te regarde
ouais il a l'air d'être tellement
s'amuser et qu'il avait rien demandé à
l'ôter persil a eu peur regardez la
merde à moto c'est le grand saut c'est
pas plus mal
shalom centré commercial pause et on
prend un petit expresso ces moments ou
pas et là il s'y attend pas mais emplois
décemment derrière le souverain pontife
a lâché m autour ipomme je veux la lpo
maire s'il vous plaît puisque l'album
c'est bien de sortir tout le monde est
là excusez moi je me bats je marche je
commanderai sur la zone sa part sur
battles d'autos tamponneuses plus tard
de apollo qu'une recrue déjà un petit
problème à les attendre on se réfugie
aux toilettes
alors je suis seul ils ont prévu un truc
à la con voilà voilà voilà deux ans déjà
est ce qu'on peut parler de l'état des
toilettes des hommes et l'état des
toilettes des filles quoi guest cydia ça
reflète pas tout la réalité voilà je
suis désolé je suis outré 1 et qui
pouvaient dépression empaillés attend
ils envoient par lui que tu es lui il
n'a pas le temps alors alors ça ça a
pété mais d'une force voilà jour 9 de
l'invasion et mais pourquoi à chaque
fois les choses me renvoie dans la mer
annonce attaquer bien me sauver je n'ai
les fonds aux mon petit éléphant mignon
qui ce qu'ils t'ont fait et ce qui est
au fait et pourquoi je suis un chien
empaillé bordel alors là ça part sur un
numéro de cirque c'est ça la chèvre
canaux me dis pas ce que je dois faire
je vais dans le canon et c'est le ouais
c'était à temps mais je crois c'est ok
attendu autour de type data guard et
amis les zombies l'éléphant le pauvre
c'est réussi c'est réussi
c'est réussi et le public est en feu ce
soir
désolé madame oh mon dieu un stand de
voyeurisme pas de voyeurisme et de
voyance c'est pas pareil alors qu'est-ce
qui a cette fois dans les caisses de aux
mondiaux que vois-je c'est le l'arc de
cupidon
ait disparue quartier pas obéi dekker
est lâche moi au menu qu'est ce qu'il
veut il m'a volé mon pain nan pétain
d'enfoiré de joueur de merde qui me
veulent mais armé qui veut me tuer
comment je fais faut que je bute ils ont
même reproduit les joueurs fdp tu te
défonces dans les jeux qu'ils volent les
armes comme ça il est passé de l'autre
côté du mur
mon dieu ils se cachent peu fébrile côté
par un homme tout nu ali qu'elle
s'apparente en singeries oh oui l'arc ya
plus de balles mais vient de disparaître
carrément est toi bien là tu vois ce
feuillet pour toi alors quelle est cette
zone à ces genres universal studios
version gold studio ah oui ok également
une belle statue de chèvre je défonce
oui voilà il est blanc comme tu y vas
brûler mon arme par trois il m'a volé
mon arme est donc battu a qu'à regarder
le lay se prend pour iron man il fait ça
carrément je te déteste
toi aussi tu détestes crois je suis dans
autour bitches mais partout à la grille
je suis sûr qu'il ya un truc à faire ici
et là dans ce truc de deux voyants je
fais comment bonjour mais non mais je
veux pas de but et je vois mon futur
aso peut-être juste que je prenne la
boule et que j'amène dans le chaudron
cette théorie de merde
adam a fait quoi la route quoi qu'est ce
qu'on a ici
ah oui c'est un show télé quoi et on
voit l'avion show tv
comment allez-vous c'est mon show
regardez je mens sur la terre mais je me
reproduit avec son chien
il a fui bordel oh non ça me fait tomber
à temps
tiens pas parce qu'on me regarde et
l'agir parterre l'aa
alors comme ça va pas voulu m'inviter
dans cette fête vip elle joue pas sur le
tapis rouge moi ou c'est vous merci
c'est évident mais voilà mais voilà on
l'a regardé il invite les gens 6 mai il
m'invite pas moi quoi c'est scandaleux
ah ah ah ah ah ouais mais bon
il ya des gens qui sont décédés non ces
aliens bon dieu qu'est ce qui se passe
ici
ok il ya également vous en avez marre de
cet alien j'ai la solution 50 ans
et voilà j'en suis bien content cette
fois la vidéo sur good c'est le dlc de
co2 simulateur je pense pas du tout
qu'on ait fait le tour du truc donc si
vous voulez qu'on fasse de doute
n'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo on ira
dans les zones qu'on a pas encore eu le
temps d'explorer on fera les craintes
qu'on n'a pas encore eu le temps de
faire que j'étais sous influence au
retour très bientôt dans une nouvelle
vidéo chat au monde pis